you don't got too good looking tonight
not to be on camera right
thank you he's always good yeah he is
yeah
you know one of the things we love about
you is the fact that you are always so
real
you're always so transparent i know
you're looking at me like this is real
crazy right
we can just say it this is some crazy
crazy
but you know what you're still beautiful
oh thank you i appreciate that i'm like
trying to really talk loud hoping you
can hear me i can hear you but um
one of the things we do love about you
because you're so transparent you're so
real both of you guys thank you
i think do you think anything about this
documentary will surprise
your fans oh god the fans know
i think i feel like the fans friends
know me
so well i think um i'm not sure
i'd love to know after the fact that's
what i'd be interested in
i think it'll mostly surprise people
that don't like me i think they might
like me after this
you know what even though they don't
want to they might i will say
you i mean first of all you are so
you're already so likable and and so
just you know thank you you really are
but then in this we see
you go from stage to backstage with the
family with the kids my favorite line of
it is
people really like uh pink because they
think she doesn't take any [ __ ]
that is my favorite life you know the
kids
mostly for me where do you get that
energy like where does it even come from
um which my sense of humor or
energy just keeping it all going just
once you start
just never stop yeah that's my my thing
i don't know i don't really know the
both of us we just
i mean i'll cook two sourdoughs before
breakfast oh my god take the kids to
school
and knit a scarf i don't know
well i i love too that you said 19 years
in you all like each other
more like than you ever did like you're
really in that was that day
i like him a lot just maybe not more
today
no thanks it's like this yeah it does
was there a moment though like that you
guys felt like
okay this is the groove we're supposed
to be in it took us a minute but
we in this groove now yeah i mean
children made us grow up a lot more
you know you can't be young and loose
and petty and
fighting as much you know with children
so children definitely made us grow up
and
prioritize and kind of get in our lane
and stay in our lane so
that definitely helped out quite a bit
yeah one of the things um pink that you
say
um about is that you know for men it's
always different
for mamas especially mamas that are
artists
like yeah you know it's yeah it is so
many quit touring because it's just hard
to be away from your kids how do you
make that all is it just like we we're
rolling together
always yeah and i you know i
credit a lot of that to carry because
carrie has his own career but
he pauses every couple of years for us
and i we are a family unit everywhere we
go
we roll together and and i'm lucky to be
able to be the boss and to call the
shots and to
create a universe in which they can
thrive
and i would say my greatest
characteristic is that i attract
beautiful human beings that's like my my
greatest talent
and i have beautiful people around me
and my kids love them and they love my
kids and
they're friends with carrie on we have
girls nights and boys nights he takes
him to a dive bar and we do our moon
ceremonies
but it works i don't know how it works
sometimes it's awful
it's awful it's impossible when the kids
are sick and
or i'm sick or anything it can be awful
too but we just like i said you just
don't stop you keep on going well you
guys also make beautiful human beings
those babies i mean
i know babies thank you singing with
your little girl
i mean i know she's so
sweet she's so unaffected and it's not
even something she wants to do
i asked her i said do you want to take
singing lessons she's like no i'm
already good at it and i was like
but you can be better because everyone
can always be better she's like yeah
no i don't want to do that i want to
what if she's the latest she wants to be
a baker and a teacher and
an amusement park an amusement park
owner she's got other ideas
the first time you thought like saw them
speak together i mean
a tear speechless what was that like for
you
yeah i mean it was pretty amazing to see
the project
because to be on the front side of the
camera like in our day-to-day lives you
know cameras rolling 18 hours a day and
then
to start seeing it edited down and
seeing it as a real project it's
you forget about some of those memories
or like some of the hardships like with
willow getting sick or alicia getting
sick like you kind of forget about those
things
as the days go on and uh it was it's you
know it's like a video yearbook
how do you feel when you see willow sing
i think it's great i love when she sings
i mean she has
you know your voice and both of our
athleticisms and she's not as crazy as
me which is good so i think she's safer
on uh
behind a microphone yeah she's a better
interviewer than i am
that's not true um you're gonna be
honored by the bill for music awards
yes icon yes that isn't that funny come
on because it's funny
come on icon i know that's what everyone
else is going to say
when you think about that think about
where you were where you came what
you've been through
in this i think there's something to be
said for perseverance
i've always told everyone i'm like a
rash i'm not going anywhere
and here i am